today we're going to unravel the
extensive web of evidence that all but
proves that Minetta will be the tenth
permanent user of one for all
now using information from the manga
anime and the ultra analysis book I have
now reached a level of consciousness
that has allowed me to see the truth for
what horikoshi has been hiding in plain
sight I'm gonna tell you guys all the
hints there not only point to grape
juice being the tenth user but we'll
also see why only he can stop the quote
singularity and we'll explain why Deku
would have no choice but to give him one
for all but before we get into that make
sure you subscribe to the channel and
yeah that's pretty much it to start with
in season 4 he notes that he can't hold
the guitar properly because of his
lackluster character design why is it
that this is the only character the only
student at least who's aware that he's a
character in a show quite similar to the
matrix where most humans lived inside a
simulation completely unknowingly the
chosen one neo was able to break out of
this mindset and thus manipulate the
matrix to his will I believe that
something similar will also be true for
grape juice as because he's aware of the
matrix that is my hero academia he'll be
able to do things that would be
impossible for other characters but
we'll get to that later as well remember
this guy's according to the ultra
analysis book Minetta is the most
intelligent male student at UA with an
almost perfect 5 out of 6 score that
makes him more intelligent than back ago
tenure deku anyone you can think of
there is no male student who has a
higher level of intelligence than grape
juice the amount of brains makes him the
ideal successor for one for all as he
can harness both the power of his balls
with one fall and use it in a way that
few characters would be able to master
the nature of his pop of quirk is
perfect for a character with his level
of intelligence as it allows him to
bounce off the balls but everyone else
sticks to them and all of that leads me
to why Minetta would be the perfect
symbol of peace as well as having the
intelligence as well as having the great
quirk and as well as being able to see
outside the matrix that is my hero
academia
Haruko she left us a very obvious clue
as to why Minetta will be the next or
might as we know the previous uses one
for all each have a meaning in their
name that corresponds with their
position for example all mites name has
the kanji for 8 which signals the fact
that he was the eighth user Mineta has
an even greater meaning than that as his
surname literally contains the kanji for
summit
a summit is the peak of something it is
the best of the best and cannot be
surpassed all might was the summit of
here Society for decades but was unable
to actually kill the evil that was all
for one and this is important because
when we read the manga it clearly says
that once role was specifically created
to defeat all for one and although all
my kind of succeeded all for one is
still alive and it's likely that his
successor shigaraki will get off one in
the future and break him out of prison
so what we need to stop him is not all
might it's not deku it is the last user
of one for all the person who will
harness the power of all the generations
and become the highest peak that cannot
be surpassed that my friends will be the
summit of one floor aka Manorama Netta
the meaning in his name clearly displays
why he will be the one to defeat
shigaraki and I'm gonna explain why Deku
will give him the quirk but let me just
explain two more things before that
because Minetta has the unique ability
to break the fourth wall this may grant
him the ability to be aware of future
arcs and storylines it only makes sense
because his character is aware that he's
in a series right in this panel he tells
arey to look him up in ten years and
whilst many of you this was blindly
interpreted as a perverted statement by
Minetta to me it's clear what he really
meant when Deku dies trying to defeat
all four one just as all the previous
holders have done except for all might
of course Airy
will need someone who can train her to
use this complicated rewind quirk
Minetta will be the best person to do
this as as we already established he's
one of the most intelligent characters
with a quirk that is arguably just as
complex if not more complex
he tells Arry to look him up because he
knows what is going to happen sort of
like dr. Manhattan Minetta doesn't
experience time in a linear fashion but
rather he experiences the past present
and future simultaneously but moving on
the second thing worth mentioning is his
close friendship to Deku and his ability
to work were than a team Deku a Minetta
worked together during the first villain
attack on UA and in fact it was their
great combination as a team that led to
several villains being defeated later in
the manga we also see that Minetta is
incredibly supportive of Deku look at
this beautiful bromance like you're not
gonna find that anywhere else and if we
take a closer look at these panels
Deku and a choco are clearly at the
beginning of their budding romance but
whilst all other characters look at
these two with
happiness in their eyes Mineta looks on
incomplete horror it's highly likely
that Mineta experiences reality
different to the other students and it's
horrified to see that one day Deku Anna
tchacos love will come to a violent end
when he's killed by over one or
shigaraki and with that said let's get
into why Deku would give him the quark
and how having one for all would help
him defeat the quark singularity so
starting with the singularity this is
the idea that quarks are evolving faster
than the human body can handle and that
in a few generations society is doomed
to be filled with people whose bodies
can't actually handle their quarks this
will lead to the extinction of the human
race and ties into the theory that
quarks of a disease believed by both
overhaul and destro who was the leader
of the meta Liberation Army bearing in
mind that quarks are a disease minetti's
hero name is an obvious foreshadow from
her akashi for those that don't know his
hero name is grape juice and when we go
on nutritionfacts.org we can clearly see
that when I study compared multiple
varieties of juice purple grape juice is
the best juice for preventing various
diseases
horikoshi has done it again people he's
done it again only he could sneak this
in there if purple grape juice prevents
diseases and quirks or disease and
quirks are evolving to a point where
they'll destroy humanity the Minetta is
clearly the one who's going to alleviate
society of the harsh burdens of their
quirks but crucially he'll only be able
to do this with the power of one for all
so my friends
why is Dec I'm gonna give him one for
all well we've seen on at least two
occasions that Deku is more than willing
to pass on this power he firstly offered
it to me Ryo during the overall arc and
it was only because Mirage fed-up
refused that Deku was able to keep the
quark then in the heroes rising movie he
fully passed the power on tobacco go so
that they could both defeat 9 and back
ago even says to him that this is the
end of your hero dream a fate which Deku
gladly accepts it was only because back
ago was not unconscious that the
previous users who once were all made
the conscious decision to go back to
Deku this is because they knew that one
day an even greater era would arise to
take on the mantle of the tenth user
Deku will pass on one for all to Mineta
as insurance before the big battle with
sugar aki
we know this because by this point sugar
aki will not just have awakened his
decay quirk will also have the power of
all for one and many other quirks
Oh Juana has accumulated throughout the
years knowing that the battle will be
hard in the same way that he passed the
quarterback who go to defeat nine Decker
will pass the collector Minetta so that
they can both defeat shigaraki as
bypassing the quirk you essentially have
double the power of one for all however
even though Minetta knows deku will die
because of what we talked about earlier
he will still but grudgingly go through
with the plan because Minetta knows that
that's what the storyline requires so
he's playing along to his part in the
story in the source material in the
actual official translation of the manga
itself Deku says in the first chapter
that this is the story of how he became
a great hero Deku will still be a great
hero after his death of he hands of
Shigure Aki and in fact he will die
happy knowing that his close friend
Mineta can complete the mission of
defeating all for one and not only that
but maleta will complete one for all and
bring it to the summit bring it to the
peak of its powers as Minetta will be
the last user i think with all the
evidence presented today it's very clear
what Hiroshi is signaling and if minutes
is not the tenth user honestly I don't
know what to tell you I think it is
almost 99% guaranteed that Mineta will
be the tenth user of one for all but
with that said be sure to let me know
what you guys think will happen in my
opinion like I said there is no doubt
that minister is the perfect character
to succeed Deku and B hence are all
indicating that and who else is gonna
stop the quote singularity and raise the
next generation of crack users I mean
it's got to be Minetta anyway thank you
guys for watching and peace out also
don't forget to subscribe see you next
time guys